the term that's been overused in
business this concept of authenticity
right all that authenticity means is the
things you say and the things you do you
actually believe
and there's a lot of room for cynicism
in the
in the in the uh
financial advisor world um because every
financial advisor says the right thing
i'm here to help you i mean hello to
help you find your nest egg to achieve
your financial goals and blah blah blah
blah blah blah every financial advisor
i've ever met tells me the same thing
but then the way they make me feel
not always consistent where they may say
the right things but then they're not
actually listening to the things that i
want i can feel that they're just trying
to hammer a product
they're not actually trying to do what i
what i exp what i talk about but rather
i can feel that feel that they have an
agenda that they're pushing something on
me and so you know we're highly attuned
social animals we can tell the
difference and if somebody's going to
put their agenda their uh
commission their interests first
then stop saying
i'm here to help you and achieve your
financial goals because i care about you
stop saying those words i don't have i
don't have a problem with somebody being
selfishly minded if they approach their
business just stop pretending
that you're not
because the ones that truly do care
will be way more creative if they say
i'm truly trying to help you they'll be
offering advice and forwarding articles
that have nothing to do with with the
financial tools that you can buy from me
i might send you an article about you
know your teenagers and and screen time
for example because you because that's
one of the things you're concerned about
and i'm here to help you live a better
life like i may be more curious about
all of the aspects of about help you of
which some are the things that i can
deliver on with the financial advice and
some financial tools so i think i think
if you got into this business to help
people then help people
um i think that's really really
important